hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
match between out of anderson and paul
charles morphy it is the second match
the two of them are playing and it is
six games of the kings gambit so this is
game six and uh morphe is already
leading the match five to zero so this
is anderson's last chance to avoid being
uh you know just crushed by six to zero
uh although what he shown what he's
shown so far in the in the king's gambit
uh it does not look promising but uh
this is the last game so let's check it
out uh and then we're going to discuss
what what what is happening so
understand with the white pieces opens
with e4 uh with e5 by morphe and now f4
going for the king's gambit e captures
on f4 knight to f3 and the g5 so
anderson did not go for the bishop's
opening uh he's now uh
trying again with knight to f3 variation
and it is what he tried in game one of
their match uh we have h4 challenging
the g5 pawn morphy accepts this plays g4
knight to e5 and now knight to f6 morphe
again with the absolute best reply
knight character son g4 and now morphy
with his uh uh never again seen gambit
because it simply doesn't work d5 we've
discussed this in length in the the last
time he played it uh but okay knight
captures on f6 banners and queen
captures and now uh in the game one that
we've already shown understand
continuing with knight to c3 and this is
uh today today to consider the strongest
reply for white here but in this game
anderson tries queen to e2 and it is now
as of move eight that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
morphy deals with this uh morphe
continues with bishop to d6 but a nice
positional idea might be d4 d4 because
white only has a queen developed it's
very difficult to develop the bishop the
the rook the knight now can be developed
the c3 so it doesn't look uh as
as good as you know white might might
want it to look but okay in the game
morphy played bishop to d6 and now
knight the c3 going after the c5 pawn
and now c6 again morphe is offering a
pawn here uh but it looks very dangerous
you don't really want to open up the e
file black might play some like king d8
bring the rook to
e8 and the white might lose the queen
but it does work uh simply capture on d5
and after uh this of course delivers
check to the black king king to d8 now
threatening rook to e8 but not a problem
knight e4 attacks the queen here and the
bishop and after the queen moves now we
pick up the bishop queen captures and
queen to f3 and white is perfectly fine
here if black tries rook to each check
we simply play bishop to eq and white is
white is better here
but okay anderson goes for d4 again he
declines the free pawn and uh well not a
free pawn but just a very tricky pawn uh
and uh sorry uh and the queen captures
on d4 by morphy uh what does anderson
play here he continues with bishop to d2
and we are only at move 11 but the
position is a complete mess so uh how do
you how do you continue here well morphy
could uh just move the move the king
away from the e file or play rook to g8
uh not castles uh castle would be maybe
a bit dangerous he plays rook the g8 now
puts his rook on a semi-open g file and
e captures on d5 with check now morphy
plays king to d8 and now uh morphe's
saying i'm gonna play rook to e8 and if
you castle well then your rook is coming
to d1 and then i'm just going to play
bishop to g4 and attack your queen and
your rook
but of course anderson being understand
this is exactly what he does he castles
queen side and this is this is a chess
equivalent of spitting in your
opponent's face basically
uh saying that to morphe okay play
bishop to g4 i really don't mind so
morphy goes for bishop to g4 and now
queen to e4 by anderson saying uh your
queen is hanging here so what do you
play well morphy says uh all right i
capture queen you capture back i capture
rook you capture the bishop here seems
like i will be up material but it
doesn't seem like there's anything
better to play here so queen captures an
e4 anderson captures back and now morphy
accepts the rook here bishop captures on
the one we have knight captures on d6 by
anderson now attacking the f7 pawn
attacking the b7 pawn the bishop still
hanging here and you have to figure out
how you want to play this so here
anderson morphe just went back with
bishop to h5 uh worthy consideration is
f3 not saying that okay if you capture
here i can capture here and my pawn is
guarded by the rook but here we would
have knight captures an f7 check and
after k8 knight g5 blocks the rooks
reach to the g2 pawn and now after let's
say bishop to e2 we could trade here g
captures on f3 bishop captures rook
captures and now let's say c captures
and d5 and we would get this position
where anderson
would be
up up upon but morphy would be up the
exchange so it'd be it'd be tricky to
play this with black even being up the
exchange because you're completely
undeveloped and a lot of things are
hanging here the white king's still in
the center of the board so what white
will be better here
but okay anderson says uh
while that's possible morphy did not go
for that he played bishop to h5 and now
uh anderson just captures the pawn on f4
uh we have c captures on the five and
now knight captures and b7 with check we
have king to e7 by morphe and now bishop
to b5 so preparing that rook to come to
e1 with check
and now morphy would really like to
continue development because he is up
the exchange but there's just no way to
do it the bishop covers all of these
squares and even if you try knight to d7
it's just losing by force uh and uh well
bishop to d6 check it just takes the
king away from the defense of the knight
it doesn't matter uh if you go here then
just rook the e1 check and if you go to
f6 then we're just gonna play rook to f1
check first and after you move it then
rook to e1 check and then after king of
six we can even play bishop to e7 check
and then we're gonna grab the knight for
example king g7 bishop captures on d7
and anderson would get his famous
evergreen bishop pair and have a
completely winning position
so instead we have rook captures on g2
now morphy has some ideas of playing
bishop to g6 and honing in on that c2
pawn but anderson just continues with
his plan rook to e1 with check and now
king to f6 if you go to f8 it's game
over the rook is controlling the e file
bishop h6 checking here and that's just
it rook to e8 will be checkmate the
bishop covering this diagonal so after
rook to e1 we've kinked the f6 but now
rook to e8 by anderson uh really really
a a nice move this completely prevents
morphe from developing anything but not
just that the knight is now being
threatened it's attacked twice and that
there really is no good way of uh
dealing with this so morphy plays a very
interesting move morphe plays bishop to
g6 attacks the c2 pawn and he says all
right what do you play here you might go
you know try and win some material but
maybe it's not gonna be all that great
but feel free to pause the video here
and try to find the absolute best move
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not playing
anything weird like rook captures on b8
because then we simply capture on b8 uh
and uh well there's not much you can do
the knight is attacked here and if you
capture the rook here with bishop
captures and b8 then we have rook
captures on c2 with check if you go here
then you go under the mask of the bishop
uh so you have to go king to d1 but then
just root captures on b1 and here black
would have uh well a hard time choosing
what what to grab so this doesn't really
work for white uh what does work for
white is the move knight to d6 and this
is by far the best bishop the e5 is fine
but uh it's not the absolute best knight
the d6
takes away the f5 square from the black
king and now as you can see pawn covers
g5 knight covers f5 the rook cuts off
the king completely from the e file and
the thread is bishop to e5 checkmate if
black does anything weird bishop to e5
is just checkmate so morphy needs to
deal with this threat so how can he do
it uh well there's there's
there aren't a lot of options you could
go king to g7 uh but this is uh
you know uh
agreeing to play a very very passive
position for a very long time for
example rook to c8 guarding that c2 pawn
and there's just no good good move for
mo for morphe king back to f6 we're just
going to play knight to e8 with check uh
you you you don't really have
a way of dealing with this if king to e7
we're gonna play knight to c7 win the
rook and that's it okay you could go for
rook captures and c to check now because
the rook isn't covering the c2 pawn but
still king d1 and the rook is falling if
you if you try rook c5 to maybe grab the
bishop after white captures the rook uh
we have this very annoying rook to e8 to
check the king now has to step away uh
we'll we're going to play some like king
to f6 and then even bishop to d6 first
we're going to chase away the rook from
attacking the bishop here then we're
going to capture the rook here so king
the g7 in this position although you
know does uh
offer some resilience and not not nearly
enough so here morphy tries knight to c6
he says all right i have to give give
something away so i might as well uh
give up uh
you know uh
not a knight but uh here rook captures
an a8 display if you capture this knight
then of course rook captures and c2 will
be uh perfectly fine for black winning
the winning bag of the bishop so here we
have rook captures on a8 and now rook
captures on c to check by morphe king d1
now knight to d4 and the morphy has uh
you know a decent amount of pieces
surrounding anderson's king but it's uh
if it's not decisive it's not decisive
and anderson has so much material so
rook back to e8 by anderson now comes
bishop to h5 with check king to e1
knight f3 check king to f1 and now
unfortunately for morphe he does not
have uh rook to f2 checkmate as the f2
square is not covered by anything so he
doesn't have a basically a better move
than to
capture upon here which he does he plays
rook captures on b2 uh and now bishop
back to e2 by anderson we have rook
captures on a2 and now uh for the final
time for the second and final time uh
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the absolute best winning
idea for anderson uh while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
wild idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's bishop to g5
with check bishop captures on f3 is fine
but bishop captures a bishop to g5 check
is just a game over uh the problem is if
you move the king let's say king g7 is
just a very sneaky checkmate knight to
f7 check the rook cuts off the king from
the back rank you have to go to g6 now
knight d7 check you have to go back and
then rook the g8 will be checkmate so
after bishop to g5 check morphy had to
capture the bishop knight captures
bishop we have h captures and now
again king g7
you just give up the bishop for free so
that's obviously not an option we have
to capture on g5 and now comes the idea
behind all of this and that is rook to
e5 with check now the bishop falls
morphy played king f6 anderson played
rook captures on h5 and he was now in
this position on move 32 that paul
morphy resigned the game and the sixth
game of this king's gambit marathon goes
to adolf anderson uh who finishes the
match by taking away a point from from
morphe uh so morphe wins the first match
rather easily seven to two with two
draws and wins the second match against
anderson uh with uh with a score of uh
five to one so incredibly impressive uh
and uh well finally the photographers
were ready and they they took a photo we
don't have the actual original of the
photo but we do have the
uh the one that we've already shown uh
so this is supposedly uh the the one as
it's on the cover of max lange's
magazine that we discussed so let's
enjoy that for a second and uh basically
this video and this game uh the sixth
game of the second match against adult
anderson is uh what marks the end of the
of the morphe saga uh morphe did play
some uh some more chess and he played
the chess for for some years but nothing
serious he played a game here and there
and a few you know matches that are
aren't really worth mentioning uh but he
never faced uh an opponent nearly as
skilled as adult anderson here so i
decided to end the saga with his second
match against anderson and there's a lot
more to murphy's life that you could
discuss but um i urge you to to get
lawson's book and paul morphy the pride
and sorrow of chess
because there's simply so much to learn
and if you guys really want i could make
like one condensed video it's probably
gonna last like an hour okay and maybe
half an hour maybe it's not gonna be an
hour but it might uh where we're just
gonna discuss everything that happened
uh you know from this point on maybe
until the the end of morphy's life in in
1884 he died at the age of 47
but i will just mention one interesting
story that happened you know of course
after this match he uh you know uh had a
had a great time with with everyone
there he uh had a dinner with anderson
and they pardoned on very good terms uh
you know understand where wherever he
came he spoke very highly of morphy and
even though when he came back to brazil
out there they were like uh how could
you lose to morphy like that you played
poorly but anderson was convinced that
he didn't the morphe was simply so
strong and
they were
they said that okay maybe you didn't
have to go to paris to face morphe
morphe's younger morphe is the one
that's you know looking for for blood he
wants to prove himself against the world
uh you should have let him come to brass
law and challenge you here you know on
your on your own turf and maybe the the
result would be different but anderson
was convinced that that would not be the
case so um that's uh you know just just
a little bit about uh what a great
gentleman anderson was and uh you know
unlike some people and why i'm ending
the saga well basically paul morphy saga
with a loss uh by morphe to adolf
andersen but as you know i'm convinced
that you guys uh agree that uh anderson
deserves it and the morphe would
definitely not mind if we asked morphe
now i think he would agree that uh you
know this this could be the last video
in the saga
uh so the thing that i wanted to mention
is that we're going to skip ahead a
little bit more if you of course return
to england and he returned to you know
home to america and then uh he uh
uh
was introduced to a very ugly truth at
some point uh staunton published yes
howard stanton our good friend who
eluded morphy so for so very long uh
published a series of games which
consisted of well a lot of games but uh
some of them were morphe's games and
there was this gentleman
named deacon that supposedly played
against morphy and two of the games that
he played against morphy were shown in
this publication one uh where morphe won
and one where this gentleman deacon won
uh but morphy after seeing this back in
new orleans set but uh you know that
event never happened i never played
against this gentleman i know of this
gentleman as i did meet him once uh when
i was in england uh but we we never
played a match uh or no not in england
in paris but they never played a match
and um uh well that was a problem
because everyone knew that uh you know
staunton was just greedy for uh for
drama as you know drama cells and there
was a lot regarding this uh supposedly
uh you know uh played match that that
happened or never happened uh but in the
end it seems that it didn't uh you know
they asked for specific details of when
the match was played and the deacon says
that the match was played at one point
where uh he and his cousin uh came up to
morphy's room and morphe was showing
them an analysis of a game he won and
then after the analysis he played a game
against deacon
and the one game he lost in the one game
he won but morphy has proof and evidence
and he has witnesses you know renowned
chess masters who
will support his claim that
well that event just never happened and
that he was not there at the specific
time uh but the there's so much about
this that you know i'm just trying to
get you to to get the book and really
really enjoy it uh but yeah
that's uh that's uh pretty much it uh
later on um as this wasn't really
explained uh very well you know uh since
you you can't really prove uh in those
days if something happened or didn't
happen it was mostly you know
credibility and you know and something
that lacks in the world today uh but
steinitz uh had a similar experience
with the same gentleman and deacon also
published some games um
where he supposedly played against
steinitz and uh stein said no that that
most definitely did not happen and when
it happened to steinitz and then you
know everyone knows that he tried to
pull the same thing on morphe then it
was pretty much agreed that the you know
the publication was a fabrication and uh
just something that maybe staunton used
to
you know sell drama because uh even
though staunton wasn't present at the
time they were played uh all of morphe's
games were published and pretty much
every game that morphe played there was
published everywhere you know on all
continents but not these games until uh
howard stanton published them so also
something that's very very interesting
and uh we're gonna be discussing what
happened in the chess world after this
point you know what happens uh
later on when steinis gets into the
picture uh because uh interestingly uh
here you you've seen morphe's match
against otto founders and he crushed him
in the first match he crushed him in the
second match uh but
uh some some years later anderson will
play a match against wilhelm stein it's
of course the the
the gentleman that will be the first
ever world chess champion uh even though
morphy's considered the unofficial world
champion but uh anderson played a
fairly fairly equal match against him uh
stein is won by a one point margin and
if you if you can if you check all of
anderson's games against steinitz uh
steinitz is up by only one point so
anderson was very much still
a formidable opponent when when he faced
steinitz but uh when he faced morphe it
simply you know it didn't go his way
where it was the trip here uh or morphe
was just that strong well i guess we'll
never know but that's the thing with
morphe because he played chess for uh
not not for very long we'll never know
how strong morphy really was because he
he kept the you know adapting he kept
developing his style he was just uh you
know doesn't matter how strong his
opponent was he always uh came out on
top and he was stronger so in this
regard i consider murphy to be like
maybe
maybe goku or or superman you know he's
always as strong as he needs to be
uh but yeah uh very very interesting but
uh also one thing i wanted to mention is
that even though morphe uh you know
pretty much retired from chess
completely he played you know some not
so serious games where he would give
opponents uh the odds of a move uh and
the pawn at least sometimes a night
sometimes more but other than his match
against
anderson here and his games he never
pretty much faced a worthy opponent
after so like i said one of the reasons
why we're ending the saga here
but anderson continued playing and he
continued having great results uh and uh
well although he lost the match to
steinitz uh the the first official world
chess championship match was between
wilhelm steinitz uh and um johannes
stukatot who was uh taught by none other
than adult anderson here so even though
he
did not contest for the for the title of
world champion himself he made sure that
his student uh is the one who who
challenges steinis for for the title
schneiderlin it's one of course but
stein it says that he would very much
prefer to have faced morphe uh
unfortunately that could could could not
happen uh but uh you know that's that's
basically it and uh okay so i don't want
to make this video too long but i would
like to
end the saga with something that we
started the saga with and that is uh you
know
a few lines from david lawson's book
on morphe that uh well we
uh we read i believe we did or maybe we
didn't i don't know because we started
the saga more than a year ago uh so let
me just
pop this up uh so as lawson says this is
the story of the birth of modern chess
when the possibilities of chess as an
art a science and the sport all
converged the point of convergence was a
young boy from louisiana named paul
morphy at a time when america was seen
as a backwards nation with little
cultural history and even less
intellectual impetus at a time when
chess was considered the exclusive
property of a few european countries
at a time when the game was played
successfully by a handful of men within
by years paul morphy in the brief span
of 19 months and with seemingly little
effort defeated conclusively every
player he ever met
while today few non-chess players know
his name he was one of the most famous
celebrities of his time and within the
hallowed halls of the chess playing
community he is considered by some as
the great greatest chess player of all
time but this diminutive unassuming boy
rose to fame almost out of nowhere and
once he secured his place in history he
retired back into that hazy unknown
shunning the public eye never again to
play serious chess not only was he one
of the great practitioners of the game
but also one of its greatest enigmas
he's been given the supra kit uh the
pride and sorrow of chess so there we
have it i hope you guys enjoyed it this
is the match against anderson this uh
concludes the morphe saga and like i
said if you guys really want we could
make like a short video of everything
that happened in morphy's life after
after the match with anderson uh but you
know if you guys really want to i i
definitely wouldn't mind
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh you know everything ended
the saga uh that's it for now uh we'll
see where where it takes us and what
will be the next saga but i'm thinking
the next saga will not be so big as you
know with so many uh current events
happening in the world it's very hard to
you know conclude such a big saga so
maybe you know like uh eight video
series of of a certain player and then
we can conclude it uh properly like
maybe in a in a week's time or two weeks
time something like that i'm thinking
for in the future
uh but yeah that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
dimitar angelo of sean vijaskera look
seems harry barton and tom derelo for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing everything else that's
happening in the chess world uh so you
know thank you all and see you soon